forces armées de regrets mais ce qui est
important pour tous les états de l'union
européenne la sécurité le soutien
économique ce qui est important et nous
apprécions beaucoup la solidarité avec
les autres pays c'est le pa2 d'emmanuel
c'est 1,2 milliard de
dettes financier pour le grain ce qui
peut nous aider à stabiliser notre
économie et ça c'est vraiment le pain
puissant pour la résistance économique
de l'ukraine
le problème de la participation de la
france dans les projets d'infrastructure
cet important et j'apprécie beaucoup que
la france participe au renouvellement de
notre structure de notre pays à
l'amélioration de vie de nos citoyens
surtout à l'est de l'ukraine
justement dans nos actions communes on
réalise
par exemple le traitement des eaux à
1010 l'eau potable à marioupol est
justement la rénovation de
des stations de traitement de l'eau à
papa semaine dans la région de lougansk
ce qui va améliorer l'eau potable des
habitants de lougansk
nous avons discuté aussi les
projets très importants c'est justement
les locomotives d'alstom
pour le grain 130 locomotive et c'est la
réalisation
de
la fabrication des navettes pour les
gardes frontière à nikolaïev elle
justement c'est la création de la
compagnie aérienne nationale d'aviation
civile
nous avons signé justement un un accord
avec encore comprendre et justement la
société française de sa laisse
et justement nous avons
discuté les problèmes de complexe
militaire de le pen
je pense que nous avons roulé pour
parler très résultats tiff je remercie
emmanuel beaucoup et je suis persuadé
que nos pourparlers ont devons donner
le coup d avance pour l'avancement de
notre pays pour la sécurité en europe
pour la sécurité agneau crème je te
remercie encore une fois merci de
soutien de le créneau merci
dans nos grandes tensions autour de
votre pays et merci pour vos mots à
l'instant
depuis la révolution de maidan en 2013
2014 le cren a choisi la voie des
réformes et de la démocratie et ce choix
a été fait par le peuple ukrainien qui
s'est mobilisé pour cet objectif et vous
le savez les européens accompagne vos
efforts de transformation qui sont aussi
une garantie de votre souveraineté
vous pouvez à cet égard vous savez
compter sur notre soutien
depuis huit ans le cren s'est déjà
considérablement transformé
et ce chemin
résolument vous en avons parlé l'un et
l'autre je m'assure lequel il n'y a pas
de marche en arrière
je veux ici rendre hommage aux
manifestants du maiden et aux milliers
de soldats morts sur le front depuis
2014 pour défendre leur patrie
il se battait pour l'ukraine
et je veux ici éviter toute forme de
simplification parfois imposées de
l'étranger parfois à des fins de
déstabilisation
monsieur le président chers volodymyr se
voulait dit tout à l'heure comme je les
dis hier publiquement à moscou dans le
contexte que nous connaissons
le sang froid dont vous faites preuve et
donc ses preuves le peuple ukrainien
face à la pression militaire
qui s'exerce à vos frontières et sur
votre territoire force le réseau
aux côtés de l'allemagne et la france
s'est déterminé monsieur le président à
suivre un assemblement ses efforts de
médiation entre la russie et l'ukraine
pour mettre fin
au conflit
nous avons eu l'occasion ensemble avec
le clan poutine l époque récente
rallièrent merkel de tenir ce qui fut le
dernier
dernière réunion en forme a dit de
normandie à paris en décembre 2019 donc
les quatre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du format normandie étaient
parvenus à se mettre d'accord sur des
mesures immédiates à mettre en oeuvre
en particulier dans le domaine
humanitaire
le 26 janvier dernier les quatre pays
ont réaffirmé leur engagement à mettre
en oeuvre les accords de minsk qui ont
vocation à rendre à l'ukraine son
intégrité territoriale
et qui trace le chemin vers la paix
hier avec le président poutine j'ai
longuement évoquée évidemment ce sujet
et s'est lui-même ré engagé à respecter
les accords de risques
et je veux ici vous remercier de m'avoir
confirmé à l'instant lors de nos
échanges de manière très claire votre
volonté de mettre en oeuvre ces mêmes
d'accord
c'est cette détermination partagée qui
est le seul chemin nous permettant de
construire la paix
le seul chemin permettant de construire
une solution politique via
je veux ici rappeler que
la base de l'accord de minsk 2 février
de mekin son objectif est entre autres
le retour des territoires séparatistes
de n'être que de loin sous la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et qu'à cet
égard les accords de minsk sont aussi la
meilleure protection de l'intégrité
territoriale
de l'ukraine
sur la base de ce double engagement
russes et ukrainiens
nous avons désormais la possibilité de
faire avancer ces négociations
beaucoup de temps a été perdu à
s'interroger sur tel ou tel format sur
telle ou telle méthode de négociation je
crois qu'il est désormais temps que tous
les participants à ces négociations
s'engagent dans un dialogue de bonne foi
le chemin est possible une autre volonté
pour ce qui est de l'allemagne et de la
france est de vous accompagner sur celui
ci
et je souhaite donc nous allons
continuer de l'évoquer ensemble à
nouveau en rentrant dans le détail mais
que nous puissions de manière très
concrète
avancées sur les sujets techniques qui
restent grâce à votre détermination
m'avait également confirmé votre
attachement au cessez le feu et une
réunion des conseillers du format
normandie aura lieu ce jeudi à berlin
je souhaite qu'elle parvienne à d'avancé
justement à la fois sur la mise en
oeuvre des mesures politiques et
humaines
ce processus de règlement
doit précisément avancé indépendamment
des tensions sur notre continent et de
la pression militaire à vos frontières
mettrait clairement en plus de ce
processus il ya aujourd'hui
une pression militaire inédit d'exit des
exercices militaires nouveau et un
risque d'escaladé
la russie en adoptant cette posture
menaçante a décidé très clairement de
mettre pression sur la communauté
internationale
j'ai eu l'occasion hier en parler
longuement avec le président poutine et
la démarche que j'ai engagées en ne
rendant à moscou et à kiev vise
précisément à
restituer collectivement ordre
stabilité et sécurité sur notre
continent est mise à mal par sa pression
militaire croissante
je crois pour ma part il y à des
solutions concrètes
pratiques qui nous permettront d'avancer
nous avons eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
ensemble j'ai eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
également avec le président pikine comme
je lé fais avec mes partenaires
européens et plusieurs de nos aînés
notre volonté pour les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois
et justement
que la situation se stabilise et une que
nous glissions réengagé
par des mécanismes de garantie nouveau
une désescalade pu rentrer
dans ce contexte le cadre ont fait
preuve la pondération
de toutes les parties prenantes dans les
propos comme dans les agressions
indispensable
vous l'avez compris
le devoir qui est le nôtre pour les
jours et les semaines à venir et
d'avancer sur ce double chemin le
premier la mise en oeuvre
résolue méthodique des accords de minsk
dans le cadre du format nombre
le deuxième
le dialogue large exigeant innovants
qui permettra de construire des
garanties
communes nouvelles et de bâtir la
sécurité et la stabilité sur notre
continent et de le faire en préservant
la sécurité de court terme
enfin le soutien de la france à
l'ukraine passe aussi par le
renforcement constant depuis plusieurs
années de nos relations vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le président nos
relations économiques financières dans
des domaines multiples comme la sécurité
civile comme le sanitaire les domaines
comme les infrastructures ou les
équipements je viens aussi à kiev dans
ce climat régional que j'évoquais de
grande tension pour marquer la confiance
que nous avons dans la résilience de
l'ukraine et son économie c'est pourquoi
nous avons décidé de mobiliser
près de 1,2 milliard d'euros sous la
forme de garanties pour financer des
projets supplémentaires
plusieurs ont été signés ou seul ont
signé ce matin
et de montrer ainsi notre confiance dans
notre économie
dans les projets qui est un gage de la
stabilité
de tout le pays
je terminerai en redisant le respect de
la france pour les aspirations du peuple
ukrainien
et la disponibilité de la france à
consolider la souveraineté de l'ukraine
comme la paix dans toute la région je
vous remercie j'ai refait
le coup pendant l'automne je crois que
je connaisse comment est un oiseau
dispose pas au top one x bretagne est
une forme assez marines éolien
s'il vous plaît
d'abord c'est un cratère et pagnol merci
adressé à aniane je voudrais poser une
petite question posée à la france vous
avez rencontré hier le président russe
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui c'est le
président est gagnant est ce que ces
rencontres ont rapproché
le rencontre des leaders de formats de
normandie leur rencontre elle est le
président la question au delà des murs
zelensky je voudrais justement que vous
faites là commentaire
je suis conscient des accords de survie
est ce qu
a
utilisé le proverbe ça te plaît aux noms
mais que doit justement avoir assez de
patience ma belle s'il vous plaît votre
commentaire
merci de votre question
il faut répondre de manière sérieuse à
cette question
disant sérieuse je vais répondre
peut-être
un russe
pour que l'auteur de citations
comprennent la réponse
en ce qui concerne des accords de misc
voilà ça te plaît ou non mais tu dois
avoir dansé de patience ma belle
naturellement
il y a des choses qu'il est difficile de
discuter du président russe le grain est
vraiment la belle
mais quand il dit ma belle ça sent peu
trop
hier vous avez eue après la rencontre le
le soir est-ce qu'il se reposait après
le repas de soir le président
aimé en ce qui concerne de patience
je considère
que le grain a assez de patience mais
c'est la sagesse et c'est important non
seulement pour le cren mais pour toute
l'europe et ce qui est important que
la russie pour la russie car de notre
patience dépend laisse kannad nous
protégeons notre pays nous sommes sur
notre territoire et notre patience
influences et les provocations comme
nous répondons pas à toutes sortes de
provocations et nous nous comportons
d'une manière digne
mais en gros c'est tout pour répondre à
votre question s'il vous plaît
pas votre question de choses la première
les discussions que j'ai pu avoir avec
le président poutine et le président
c'est nice qui ont permis de
progresser sur des voies et moyens de
bâtir cette sécurité stabilité dans la
région
et de ne pas rester enfermés dans des
schémas univoque
ceci prendra du temps
et doit s'accompagner
d'une baisse de la tension en
particulier militaires mais rien ne peut
remplacer ces discussions en profondeur
pour essayer justement de rapprocher les
vues et faire baisser la tension
les résultats mettront du temps à être
produit parce que nous parlons là d'un
ordre
géopolitique qui a été bâti dès la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale et de
plusieurs décennies
de désaccord ou malentendu mais je pense
pour ma part utile d'aller en profondeur
sur ces échanges est aussi comme
d'ailleurs les communications des
dernières heures ont permis de le faire
de clarifier
plusieurs éléments sur les postures et
de faire baisser la tension la deuxième
chose
c'est que j'ai pu durant ces échanges
obtenir l'engagement très clair et
explicite des présidents poutine des
inédits qui de
s'engager sur la base d'un stricte des
accords de minsk et en particulier sur
le strict respect de plusieurs
procédures qui sont un peu technique
n'entendrait pas ici dans le détail nous
en avons parlé l'un et l'autre j'ai payé
en parler avec le président poutine mais
qui donneront lieu à des échanges
d'ailleurs dès aujourd'hui au sein du
groupe de contact tripartite et à berlin
dans la discussion qui se tiendra au
niveau de nos sherpas
les choses doivent continuer d'avancer
conformément à une compréhension commune
des textes qui ont été signés en 2015 et
je pense pour ma part que en effet cet
échange en possible si nous savons
avancer sur ces discussions est là la
clarification de ses textes sur une
rencontre dans les prochaines semaines
tout cela n'est possible que si
collectivement nous arrivons à ce que le
leucan l'instabilité
le respect réciproque sont maintenus ce
qui est aussi un des objectifs de
ces échanges et s'est vite
avec une serre où gbagbo bosque
oui bonjour de gagner ce baume de
bloomberg bonjour monsieur le président
monsieur le président ma craint une
question pour vous il ya vous avez dit
que la finlandisation de l'ukraine était
une des options sur la table quand on
dit vous par là et deuxième question
vous avez aussi dit avoir obtenu des
assurances sur la vie des escalades de
la part du président poutine mais d'ores
et déjà le kremlin dit qu' il n'y a
aucun engagement de la part des russes
de jeu les progrès de leur présence
militaire et d'ukraine donc est ce que
vous avez eu des engagements plus
concrets sur cette escalade et est ce
que vous êtes peut-être déçus de cette
rencontre avec monsieur poutine est une
question aussi pour le président
zelensky quelle est selon vous la
première étape de l'application du
désaccord de minsk et comment est ce que
vous avez trouvé finalement vladimir
poutine il hier lors de la conférence de
presse avec votre homologue française
que vous l'avez trouvé plus ouvert qu'à
l'accoutumée est ce que ça vous a rendu
confiants trop pas
sur votre première question enfin vos
deux questions qui me sont annoncés je
dois être prêt si je n'ai utilisé aucune
de ces formules
et vous ne m'avez jamais entendu dire le
mot que vous avez utilisé pour ce qui
est de l'ukraine je n'ai d'ailleurs pas
fait de comparaison j'ai dit que mettre
fin à la politique de portes ouvertes de
l'otan serait un problème pour plusieurs
états européens dont la finlande et la
suède par exemple donc je ne crois pas
que la russie vaillant confirmer les
perspectives mais je pense que
comparaison n'est pas raison et je n'ai
jamais je me suis jamais rentré dans ce
type de formule que vous venez d'avoir
je pense est très important d'avoir
cette clarification ni dans des propos
tenus à l'est avec des journalistes ni
dans la conférence de presse d'hier soir
donc je pense que il faut ici être très
vigilant et très clair dans un situation
que nous connaissons il y à une
situation qui est le conflit russo
ukrainien
cette situation hélas un cadre les
accords de minsk il forma normandie
c'est le seul et il ya une situation qui
s'est dégradée aux frontières par le
déploiement de troupes une tension
accrue avec un processus qui lie à celui
ci un échange de lettres entre la russie
et l'otan la russie et les etats unis
d'amérique dont
le coeur de la discussion et la question
de l'otan je sais parler de sujets à
dessein car ils sont historiquement
séparer
la question sous jacente qui est posée
c'est celle de la sécurité collective
des mesures de transparence de confiance
de désescalade dans toute la région
je dis que cette question ne se réduit
pas à la question de l'otan et de son
extension
cette question recouvre beaucoup
d'autres sujets et des processus de
confiance
et d'avancer très concrète et donc en la
matière c'est une discussion que j'ai
eue avec le président poutine je pense
qu'il nous faut poursuivre le dialogue
et nous avons commencé à échanger et du
change sont très riches avec le
président sur justement les voies et
moyens de faire respecter nos principes
et nos valeurs mais je le redis ici
comme je lé d'hier
quelques architecture que nous arrivions
à bâtir quelque ordre nouveau que nous
cherchons à mettre en place il ne peut
être que respectueux des principes que
nous nous sommes de mai nous mêmes il ya
trente ans le respect de la souveraineté
des états l'intégrité territoriale le
respect des droits nous les avons signé
de tous les uns et les autres la russie
la france l'ensemble des pays concernés
et donc cet ordre continue à prévaloir
pour ce qui est ensuite
de la discussion sur la question plus
militaire et sécuritaire
nous avons comme je les dis très
précisément vers échangé avec le
président pour qui il m'a dit qu'il ne
serait pas à l'origine d'une escalade
je pense que ça a son importance
j'ai noté ce matin la confirmation des
engagements qui ont été pris puisque le
deuxième élément important c'est qu'il
n'y aurait pas de base fixe ni de
déploiement d'équipements sensibles en
biélorussie
je crois que ça a été confirmé voilà
pour le reste nul n'est naïf les
déploiements récents sont liées à une
situation de tension et vous ne m'avez
pas entendu hier
annoncer quoi que ce soit sur ce sujet
ce sera le fruit d'un processus que nous
avons ouvert je pense que comme vous
m'avez entendu le dire il faut rien
sous-estimé de l'attention qu'il ya
autour de la situation nous sommes en
train de vivre et de son caractère
inédit sous sa forme multiples
la france depuis le début de cette crise
n'a jamais tenu des propos excessifs
en la matière
mais de la même manière je ne considère
pas qu'on puisse régler cette crise
quelques heures de discussions nous
avons donc cherché en lien très étroit
avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires
européens et nos alliés à faire
respecter nos valeurs
l'importance de la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale dans la région
dans la région et à amorcer un nouveau
processus mais ce sont les jours les
semaines et peut-être les mois qui
viennent qui nous permettront ensemble
de me faire progresser voilà comment je
vois les choses
dieu merci de votre question je suis pas
certain que je j'ai bien compris votre
question
s'il vous plaît je vais attendre
je voudrais bien comprendre
est-ce que
non non je vais justement poser la
question si j'ai bien compris
si le président de la russie pendant la
pré conférence de presse était ouverte
où étaient ouverts
c'est ça ce que je bien compris
et en quoi consiste la question alors il
a été ouvert
alors à quoi cela est lié
[Musique]
jacques tortos iazev prime time merci
comment je comprends honnêtement je vais
vous dire ir j'ai pas regardé la
conférence de presse je n'ai pas de
temps moi je comprend l'ouverture de
tout leader
l'ouverture c'est bien c'est toujours
bien si c'est la vérité
si c'est pas le jeu mais si c'est
l'ouverture sérieuse et la compréhension
qu'il y a l'insécurité c'est pas la
plaisanterie au mans je pense que c'est
positif
les paroles je suis pas toujours
confiant aux paroles car je pense que
tout politicien pour l'ouverture c'est
le cas réels dans notre cas ce sont les
pas vers la dsca dad et pour ça je pense
que si cette personne est ouverte
pour ça cette personne a tout le
nécessaire
absolument tout est ce que vous venez de
dire les messages qu'ils récente qu'il
n'est pas le sujet de l' escalade que
c'est la pression à mon avis je ne sais
pas le sujet en europe qui pourrait
imposer faire la pression sur la
fédération de russie d'une manière
puissante
de toute manière la dea d'expression de
notre pays nous ne la constatons pas
mais je veux revenir au pain les
premiers pas ce que manuel vient de dire
nous avons une plateforme de discussion
c'est le format de normandie noms sont
contents de leur rencontre de nos chers
pas qui va réaliser les jours prochains
s'il ya cette ouverture est justement je
pense qu'on aura la rencontre des
leaders est justement là on pourrait y
manifester son sujet et ce à son
ouverture les défis y en a beaucoup et
les appels il y en a beaucoup
il ya la finalisation comme vous venez
de dire
mais la féminisation de l'ukraine c'est
je l'entends pour la première fois
nous prenons à personne l'oganisation
d'impayés ou l'autre je pense que tout
pays et souveraine c'est son avantage
mais en ce qui concerne des shoes des
mots des paroles
ya pas longtemps une personne un
camarade de la biélorussie a déclaré que
si on à l'escaladé de la peur de la
russie tout de suite
ils vont arrêter de
livrer l'énergie vers le crem cette
personne a dit ces paroles comment doit
réagir en haut je vais vous expliquer
moi j'ai demandé les chiffres d'un
échange commercial entre nos états entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
nous avons six milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
un
milliard et demi c'est l'exploitation de
lincoln et
4,5 c'est la biélorussie si
les pays commencent à réduire leur
commerce entre eux qui souffrent
dans ce cas
c'est tout simplement les citoyens les
gens qui vont souffrir si on veut
revenir aux époques préhistoriques
de toute manière ce sont les politiciens
qui décide et souffre leur population
et donc justement de cette perte de 6
milliards c'est pas le crâne qui va
gagner donc dans ce cas les pas concret
et les pas au vert c'est mieux que les
paroles merci
merci le temps de parole est terminé
mais on continue la manifestation
commence la cérémonie de la signature
action
le président de la société aux crises
non exécution et le président de alstom
n'est pas par lafarge signent le
mémorandum de la compréhension et des
intentions entre la société au
catholicisme est la société alstom
par lafarge président directeur général
d'alstom signer un protocole d'accord
entre la société alstom et houplin
l'initia
[Applaudissements]
cérémonieux pesaro tronyo la cérémonie
de la signature est close
héros est terminée
de juniac
nous vous remercions beaucoup
l'os